please put me in you and let me wiggle
around until I start spinning wildly
Halloween is a time for ladies to dress
sexy and dudes to dress stupid straight
dudes are obsessed with dicks that's
just funny naturally every Halloween see
a bunch of dudes wearing gross dick
costumes wow why the is everyone
talking about penises so much they're
fluffy they get hard
they have little funny hats guys should
try to look sexy on Halloween too and
the least sexy thing you can do is to
look like a pervert we're gonna join
another fun I'm fully naked and ready to
try on some Halloween costume mud and
Halloween fish inspired by the Middle
East and like a droopy hot dog
it's a snake charmer I was promised
penis the inference is that my dick is
gonna bite you is it a little racist
I just put it between my butt cheeks oh
the snakes got no eyes it's a shitty
snake I'm gonna have a fake dick at
least I want a cool fake dick the best
use of this is just to scare people
I think this is a good idea oh wow
something bit me or something in the
suit this better not be a spider in here
with the sound of culturally insensitive
dick comedy for Reid breathalyzer tests
first of all the guy in the costume
looks like PewDiePie you're supposed to
blow on the day has this ever worked it
would have to be really wasted to find
your attractiveness also if you want
someone to suck your dick wear something
cute
nothing made my butt look good
worthless I'd rather go as a hot vacuum
cleaner because at least the function is
cool why is there pie chart' scraps it
makes sense to me that the math on here
doesn't make sense because I assume
anyone who wears this costume did flunk
out of school but if I saw somebody
wearing this I probably suck their dick
there's nothing less sexy than a sex
offender this next was special this is
the sexy Bernie Sanders costume oh I
just grabbed it by the dick
now I'm horrifying so this outfit is
called the flasher I'll show you why
honey
they only come in white all right the
big problem with this costume that's not
how a nut sack works if they don't eat
to get the roll bag my wife would
divorce me if I were this it's awful
however I'm excited to see a montage of
everybody trying to helicopter with it
it's not the true weight of a penis see
you later boner body
oh hello boner body dude just stick it
in it's got a long shaft this is what a
sperm must feel like I've always
wondered what it would be like to be a
huge embarrassment to my family wrong
hole I'm a penis has a beard they'll be
funny if it had a hole for your actual
dick to stick out dicks up
obviously the life of a party where do
you put your wallet and keys have a
history of not liking giant dick I feel
like this is something some fashion
designer would send down the Paris
runway oh this does kind of look like
the easy line doesn't it
how does my head look do I look
uncircumcised now how cute would it be
if we just had a nice little shoulder
shawl you put a little hood there really
me over with padding I think
everybody in the world can agree that
this is too funny now let me run around
Oh
[Music]
let me inside of you what what else do
you say when you hear a big bit look at
me I'm the of the walk
it's not it's not that you're wearing a
dick costume it's how you wear it
the only way that I would be cool with
this is if I saw a bunch of girls
wearing this you go girl
you own that dick Oh God you just throw
vagina at me well if we thought the
penis was bad someone dropped it on the
ground our vaginas dirty already just
got a little bit in there this actually
is very similar to costumes my mom would
make for me when I was a kid in
construction this isn't a great vagina
12 cute first off you can't penetrate it
where's the clitoris mighty it's my
facebook clitoris
oh my god I'm the clitoris or you rub it
teaching kids about sex who's your
audience keep that closed till you're
ready to get pregnant
cuz that's what'll happen if y'all kids
have sex at the very least there should
be a hole so I could like throw babies
at people from the inside of my stomach
this is fetus Eugene what a toasty
vagina hey in this this is the
warmest vagina I have ever been in this
is like negative sexy points one giant
vagina is gonna keep all the vaginas
away I promise you that I want to know
who buys these costumes they're all
gross my advice is don't wear these you
know if you want to dress up as a giant
dick or giant vagina go ahead just know
that people probably are gonna want to
not talk to you again what's weird is
that I feel the vibrations if you blow
any vibrators my dick so it is doing
something hey